wir haben dir eigentlich keine klemmt im
restaurant hirsch eine tasche und
serviert kleinklasse signalisiert und
sind wir lange bis ich wollte keine
schweizer freund habe dann finden fühle
ich mich ein bisschen wie sagt man
geteilt so schweiz portugal
aber dann sah ich habe mich verliebt was
kann man machen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
christina und markus leben in einem dorf
im oberwallis das einzigartig ist in der
schweiz
hier wurden mehr ausländer als schweizer
wie ist es in einem dorf zu leben in dem
die schweizer bevölkerung in der
minderheit ist verliert es dadurch seine
identität und wer sind die menschen hier
davon handelt dieser film
von den rund 1500 einwohnern im dorf
sind 60 prozent ausländer
hauptsächlich portugiesen sie leben in
täsch arbeiten aber vorwiegend im
nahegelegenen zermatt wo sie für das
reibungslose funktionieren der
tourismusbranche sorgen hinter den
kulissen versteht sich als tellerwäscher
portiers zimmermädchen oder chauffeure
ohne sie würde hier am fuß des
matterhorns gar nichts gehen
ich mache mich auf dieses dorf im wallis
kennenzulernen
ich will herausfinden wie die menschen
hier miteinander leben und auskommen wie
funktioniert die integration und wer
passt sich hier wen an tatsächlich höre
ich in den gassen fast nur portugiesisch
und wäre nicht das matterhorn in der
nähe wende ich mich fast schon in einem
mediterranen dorf auf den ersten blick
also alles idyllisch und in sachen
integration offenbar auch engagiert doch
auf den zweiten blick sieht es bereits
etwas anders aus
meine erste station ist die tatsche
dorfbeiz ein guter ausgangspunkt für
meinen streifzug durchs dorf hinter der
theke arbeiten zwei portugiesinnen die
kundschaft ist vorwiegend schweizerisch
eine der kellnerinnen ist christina
maria die sich in den schweizer markus
hütsch verliebt hat sie lebt seit drei
jahren im dorf und fühle sich wohl meint
sie
auch wenn das leben hier ganz anders sei
als in portugal an einem der tische
treffe ich auf das ehepaar treffer die
beiden leben seit vielen jahren tisch
und haben die gesellschaftlichen
veränderungen im dorf hautnah miterlebt
das sind richtige kleine das sind
richtige ganze dörfer war für portugal
hat und das leder schon kann man das
hassen sie verstehen dass wenn aber was
ich mit denen man wird keine nachricht
aus wörtlich man kann zusammenleben
begrüßen hallo und zusammenleben zb
einlage nahe kommt zu mir ich glaube das
gibt es nicht zu finden
ich werde keinen den sprachlichen mit
der kleber mit mitglied war
die drei mitglieder war war ich brauche
das gefühl und daher geht das nicht
ausprobiert heimischen probiert
ein ort wo diese sprachbarrieren
tagtäglich abgebaut werden ist die neue
schule von tesch die vielzahl der hier
ansässigen portugiesen machte den bau
überhaupt erst notwendig
[Musik]
über 70 prozent der schülerinnen und
schüler ihr sind ausländer
die herausforderungen an die lehrer sind
groß jede klasse hat ihren eigenen
integrations unterricht besteht das
risiko dass in der schweizer klinik
portugiesisch lernen dass die
portugiesische also die sowie diesem
schild sprach hochdeutsch das ist schon
kinder oder so und das ist hier ein
regel in shirts immer im schulhaus wird
die gerettet aber ist natürlich klar
dass die kinder auf dem pausenplatz auf
einmal zusammen verkommen oder mit
verkommen und einzelne werte lägen aber
so ganz klar es wird geleert und die
gleich neben der schule gibt es einen
kleinen laden mit ausschließlich
portugiesischen lebensmitteln christina
maria es kommt oft zum einkaufen hierher
spezialitäten aus portugal frisches brot
und der typische geruch des in salz
getrockneten fisches verleihen dem ort
einen hauch von heimat und er ist für
viele ein willkommener treffpunkt
gibt es auch fisch das ist wirklich zu
wissen dass man in der schweiz die
schweizer geschäft bekommt man nicht
es ist nicht so schwierig habe
[Musik]
kartoffeln aus dem wallis olivenöl aus
spanien und pfeffer aus porto das ist
das geheimnis einer guten rutsch die
mainzer monteiro denn der hochsaison
täglich 300 portionen davon zubereitet
ungefähr 2600 wenn zahlen alles das ist
alles viel zu tolerieren
so war die krankenkassen entwarnung und
auch so lässt nichts passt nichts und
dieses geld schicken sie nach hause nach
portugal oder sparen sie zeit sparen
nichts was ich sofern ich weiß dass du
musst auch lehren muss meine größte rand
aber ich muss dann kauft man etwas
kaufen oder ich muss meinen oder noch
werden
seit einem halben jahr arbeitet schnell
als küchenhilfe auf der bergstation des
klein matterhorns auf 3900 meter über
meer vom bergpanorama sieht er hier
wenig es gibt keine fenster in der
kleinen küche und damit keine ablenkung
von risotto bratwürsten und sechs tage
die woche zehn stunden pro tag
ich würde alles tun ich ja wohl immer
noch zu haben sind schon zu perfekt
[Musik]
montero kam vor vier jahren in die
schweiz
die wirtschaftskrise in portugal hat den
migrations fluss in den letzten jahren
beträchtlich erhöht in orten wie zermatt
herrscht akute wohnungsnot viele
gastarbeiter leben deshalb in teschow
wohnt in einem ein-zimmer-appartement
seine nachbarn sind vorwiegend
portugiesen
wie lange wollen sie schon hier ein
bisschen mehr als 770 in serm hat aber
die hier ich sagen nicht so viel weniger
was zahlen sie hier
500 franken
besucht seine familie in portugal einmal
im jahr während der sommerferien einsam
fühle er sich nicht meint er
er hat eine portugiesische freundin in
zermatt und freunde die er manchmal
abends zu einem bier trifft ich bin
nicht alleine ich brauche nur einen
moment ruhe
allein in meiner hause zu passieren
müssen spaß machen und dann erfahre ich
vom portugiesischen hilfskoch dass er
eigentlich ausgebildeter klarinettist
ist vor der krise hat er in portugal in
einem kammerorchester gespielt und
schüler unterrichtet
[Musik]
wenn ich spiele ich vergesse aber ich
habe nicht so viele probleme aber ich
vergesse ich konzentrier musik und ich
[Musik]
schwimmen ich wie man ihn in meinem 1
weltmeister das ist sehr selten
[Musik]
abends ist nicht viel los am bahnhof
entdecke ich eine beiz mit raucherecke
hier treffen sich ausschließlich junge
portugiesen zum kartenspielen oder bier
trinken
einer von ihnen ist bruno der hier nach
der arbeit seine freunde trifft es sei
langweilig wie junge leute meint bruno
der davon träumt einmal als mode
verkäufer in die großstadt zu ziehen
nach luzern oder zürich ohne und seine
freundin laden mich zum essen ein
sie leben zusammen mit brunos eltern in
einer dreizimmerwohnung der vater
arbeitet seit vielen jahren als
hotelportier in zermatt bonus mutter
macht die betten und reinigungsarbeiten
und seine freundin carolina arbeitet als
coiffeuse das kleine mädchen auf ihrem
schoß ist die tochter des nachbarn und
oft hier zu besuch
wenn seine eltern noch arbeiten zu hause
wird portugiesisch gesprochen und auch
bei der arbeit sprechen die eltern kaum
deutsch schwierig ich habe einfach reden
ich habe schwierig verschieden
[Musik]
im italienischen die familie cardoso
lebt seit zwölf jahren in tisch ich will
von ihnen wissen ob sie sich von den
tätern akzeptiert wie sie alle sind da
die liter so unter anderem kommuniziert
uns und wir merkten dass das gegen ein
paar seiten scheiße schweiz und
schließen das wir hoffen dass das geld
machen
was würde der markt da schon die
portugiese das ist aber die frage
ohnehin
[Musik]
am 9 februar haben die schweizer sich in
einer knappen abstimmung für die
masseneinwanderung initiative
ausgesprochen
der kanton wallis hat die vorlage
insgesamt abgelehnt
doch wo die schweizer bevölkerung in der
minderheit ist wurden 66 prozent ja
stimmen in die urne gelegt ein klares
votum an die ansässigen gastarbeiter und
an all die die noch kommen wollen
und doch sind genau damit viele
portugiesen einverstanden
auch sie wollen nicht noch mehr
gastarbeiter die ihre stellen und ihre
zukunft in der schweiz bewerben
und sie finden es also auch nicht gut
wenn noch mehr gastarbeiter nach tisch
kommen
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen treffe ich auf den
bahnangestellten und freizeit landwirt
toni moser dessen familie seit
generationen in täsch lebt er gehört zu
den wenigen stimmberechtigten im dorf
die die initiative um abgelehnt haben
ich will von ihm wissen was er für einen
kontakt hat zu den gastarbeitern im dorf
ich hatte mich bereits als potenziellen
damit sie kaum von der beruf musiker
kollege war
portugal war damit spielen und die
machen ihre sache sehen wird die weise
also nieder das des landes oder das ist
spitze bei stickstoff prinzip dass eine
tote fällen musik und nicht die
nationalität
[Musik]
ich begleite duell noch einmal hoch auf
das kleine matterhorn
fast alle mitarbeiter vom berg betriebs
in ausländer italiener albaner oder
kroaten
einzige ausnahme ist schon als
küchenchef der seit vielen jahren
täglich mit gastarbeitern zu tun hat für
seine ausländer lege er die hand ins
feuer meint er stolz
und trotzdem hat auch er für die
initiative gestimmt
portugal will smi portugiesen als das
und darum werden es ziemlich sicher die
abgestimmt haben und weg sind sie dass
mit der neuen regulierung für die
wanderung plötzlich nehmen es auch viele
gastarbeiter danach eingeschlafen
was wird denn passieren mit der macht
oder mit
ich glaube mit der neuregelung wieder
ins gas corp durch es wieder
interessanter ist schaffen und sondern
entwickelt würden sie also begrüßt
mit dem schweizer linda der tochter und
die riesige portugiese solle die heime
bliebe wie gut der blieben doch die
schlacht beginnt das ist auch in ordnung
ich bin überzeugt dass das akku dies
auch ich bin überzeugt dass wir die
qualität von business erhöhen
also das heißt der schule blieb das soll
bleibt ganz ruhig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zurück bei christina der kellnerin aus
der tasche dorfbeiz sie lebt mit markus
rusch zusammen deren bilic alter des
taser bahnhofs arbeitet die beiden haben
sich bei einem jahr kennengelernt und
ineinander verliebt und weil es auch
leute die euch darauf ansprechen oder
die hinter ihrem rücken darüber sprechen
das gibt sicher tragen sich schon wie
hat jetzt die kennengelernt und warum
die portugiesen meine kollegen lawrow
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht dann in die rücken west
design habe sind neidisch
hättet ihr euch jemals vorstellen können
mit einer portugiesin oder mit einem
schweizer zusammenzukommen
vor einem jahr habe ich gesagt ja nie im
ausland
ich habe immer gedacht ich habe nie
gedacht dass ein trottel interesse für
gewinner gibt es einige
wir machen also da nicht etwas sagen
denn anfang oder etwas angst es ist
schön dass das so funktioniert und ich
glaube es trägt auch dazu bei die ängste
und die diffusen ängste oder wie die
abgeschottet hat ein bisschen
aufzumischen
man erzählt seinen kollegen und freunde
wie das ist und dann ist das eigentlich
das selbstverständlich
natürlich dass es überhaupt gibt vor
allem wir sind menschen die unterschiede
sind nicht so groß wenn sie überhaupt
existieren mitdenken ungefähr gleich
und wären nicht nur bei christina und
markus der frühling zu spüren ist stellt
der musikverein tal bei einer kleinen
fangemeinde ein neues stück vor
das orchester hat seit kurzem drei neue
mitglieder allen voran der berufsmusiker
joao monteiro und zwei weitere
portugiesen die pauke haut toni moser
der landwirt dagegen die initiative
gestimmt hat und apropos abstimmung über
die aufnahme der neuen mitglieder ins
orchester musste intern abgestimmt
werden
denn seitdem gut 100 jährigen bestehen
des musikvereins gab es hier noch nie
einen ausländer
die abstimmung fiel ohne gegenstimme für
die portugiesen aus
und damit endet diese geschichte über
ein dorf im wandel bis aus dem
nebeneinander ein miteinander wird wird
wohl noch ein wenig zeit vergehen
doch die zeichen stehen gut ich verlasse
ein gar nicht so untypisches schweizer
dorf von identitätsverlust kann keine
rede sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]